SCOTT WIENER: Thanks
for having me back.
Last time I came in,
we did a discussion
about the various styles of
pizza that exist in New York,
and what the differences
and similarities are,
and that was a whole lot of fun.
And I think the
whole talk ended up
being over an hour of just
straight discussion of--
Were any of you guys there?
OK, so you remember what it was.
It was just talking pretty--
AUDIENCE: And eating.
SCOTT WIENER: Yeah, and eating.
Yeah, that's right.
The table was covered in pizza.
And in the past year,
I've had so many people
who've come on tours and
been like, yeah, I found out
about you because I watched
this hour and eight minute
long video of you
standing in front
of a wall talking about pizza.
And it just blows my mind.
I'm like, really?
You watched that?
I figured that, you
know, these things go up,
and it's just kind of
like, you know, it's there
just in case you need
it in the future.
But no, it was just
really, really funny.
So this book just came out
in November, and when it did,
I was just kind of trying
to brainstorm about,
you know, I want to
talk to some people
about what this book is about,
because every time I mention
what it's about, which is
just about pizza boxes,
it begins this
flurry of questions.
And so what I want to talk to
you guys about are pretty much,
I want to answer
all these questions
before you have a
chance to ask them.
And then once I go
through some stuff,
if you have any other questions
about, of course, pizza--
I cannot ban you from
asking pizza questions--
but specifically, this project.
I'd never written a book before,
and in doing all the work
that I do, there's so many book
projects that come to mind.
But there are also a
lot of books about pizza
that are out there already.
But the thing that I
really wanted to focus on
was, first and
foremost, I wanted
to get away from what everybody
else was talking about,
which is subjective things
like what food tastes like.
Or like cookbooks, which I
know, I cook some pizza at home
sometimes, but I'm not
going to write a cookbook.
But I also happen to
collect pizza boxes.
And that's just a huge
thing, like, literally
in the closet for me.
And I wanted to bust
it out of the closet,
and that's what this is.
So yeah.
I run towards, for anybody
who did not come last time,
or has never been on
a pizza tour with me,
I run tours of pizzerias--
famous pizzerias.
And I take people all around.
And as Greg said, I get to go
to places like the International
Pizza Expo and judge
pizza competitions.
I was just at a pizza convention
in Brazil, in Sao Paulo,
to talk about pizza box design
and pizza box variations
in New York City.
And that was pretty fun.
I'm going to show
you some pizza boxes
that I picked up on that trip.
They are bonkers.
Seriously.
I know it sounds crazy when I
say something like that a pizza
box could be bonkers, but I
guess the best way to even get
into talking about this is I
want you just do me a favor.
Close your eyes,
if it helps, but I
want you just picture
a pizza box, OK?
From the top.
Like the top down.
And you can open your
eyes if you want, OK?
Wait, I don't know what this is.
Anyway.
Pizza box.
This is probably what most of
you were thinking about, right?
White with red
smudgey inky printing.
Totally boring.
Totally generic.
It says something like the
word pizza, which is obvious,
because anytime you
have a square box that's
two inches deep, that's what's
in it, you know what I mean?
You see a movie
that has that box,
it can have no printing on
it, and you know, pizza.
There's no other food that
you see the container,
and you think immediately
about the food itself.
Like maybe an ice cream cone,
but that is part of the food.
There's no steak box,
you know what I mean?
There's no spaghetti container.
Chinese food, I
guess, is one thing,
but even now, everybody's using
plastic containers instead
of that.
But this has been
pretty much the same
for the past 65, 70 years.
And of course you start off
by thinking about pizza boxes
like this, especially
in New York--
this white with red
smudgey inky printing.
But I collect pizza boxes, and I
have over 720, 725 pizza boxes.
And that slide that I went past.
Right.
Spoiler alert.
I have the world's largest
collection of pizza boxes
as certified by the Guinness
World Records Organization,
and that is true.
So just to let you know,
I want to use this time
to take you through
what that collection is,
and what it means, and
why I collect pizza boxes.
Because when you think
about pizza boxes like this,
then it's like, a collection of
them, to most people, is like,
this guy just doesn't
throw out his garbage.
And I want to just make it
very clear that I do throw out
my garbage.
I'm pretty good at that.
But I also like to save
pizza boxes that are unique.
Pretty much the reason why I
collect pizza boxes is in 2008,
I saw a pizza box that did not
look like this red inky smudgey
printing on white cardboard.
It was yellow.
It was in Israel, so right away,
there's Hebrew writing on it,
and it's a yellow box, and
it's got blue writing on it.
And that just blew
my mind right away.
I don't know if that
would blow your mind.
But now that I've
been collecting
a bunch of pizza boxes
I found, boxes from 45,
50 different countries that
are totally, totally amazing.
This is the reason
that I collect
pizza boxes is that this
is a real pizza box.
This is a photograph of the
actual cardboard box sitting
on a wooden table in my
apartment, and that's it.
But it's a painting.
This is mass produced.
There are thousands of these
probably now in the garbage.
But a pizzeria delivers
your pizza in this.
And right off the bat,
different from the pizza boxes
I showed you before.
It doesn't say any words on it.
It says one word
on the whole box.
I know you probably
can't see it,
but in the lower left hand
corner, it says, C-I-A-N-C-I-O.
Ciancio, the artist's name,
signed on the image that was
used for the box.
Ciancio, I later
found out, is probably
the most prolific pizza
box artist in the world.
He's done 250 designs that
have landed on pizza boxes,
and this is just
one that I thought
was kind of creepy,
but also just amazing
that you get a pizza
with this in it.
And I feel like I would
hesitate more than normal
before I open up the box,
just looking at that.
But anyway, of the boxes that
I have, over 700 of them,
I have so many
that are like this
that now when people
send me pictures of them,
and they're like, look at
this crazy box I found,
I feel so terrible sometimes
when I'm like, I got it.
I got that one.
Don't worry about it.
But then all the time, I get
pictures that people send me,
and oh, it's amazing.
And then I say, oh,
yes, can you send it?
What's the cleanliness
factor on the inside?
Because I try to
get clean boxes.
And he goes, oh,
it's pretty bad.
Pulled it out of the dumpster.
And then I hate to do it,
but I say, let this one go.
Just let it go.
But anyway, the whole pizza
box collection kind of
started back in 2009.
So I run this company
called Scott's Pizza Tours,
and every year, we do a big
fundraising event called
Slice Out Hunger, which we
get a bunch of pizzerias--
like 45, 50 pizzerias
in a room in SoHo.
They all bring 30 or 40 pizzas.
We sell the pizza
for $1.00 a slice,
and all the money we raise gets
matched by a bunch of sponsors
that we have.
And all that money goes to the
food bank for New York City.
So in 2009-- this is last year.
This is more recent.
But in 2009, we raised
maybe $800, $900.
Then the next year,
we raised over $1,000.
And then the next year,
we raised over $10,000.
And then last year
we raised $20,000.
And this year coming
up in October--
not really coming
up soon, but October
is National Pizza Month,
so we do it in October.
We're going to raise $50,000.
So every dollar that
we send the food bank
provides five meals for
the homeless in New York.
So we're going to feed a
quarter of a million people
just with three hours
of pizza eating.
And I had no idea.
Foolishly enough,
I did not think
that having pizza from
amazing places that
don't sell by the slice, like
Lombardi's, or like places that
do sell by the slice but
are expensive, like Di Fara
and incredibly far away, of
course-- I didn't think that
was enough of a draw.
So when we started the event--
Here's what the event
looks like now, last year.
It's really funny,
because there's
this one girl in the middle
of the frame just staring
at the camera.
Creeps me out every time.
Oh, and she's
holding that box we
were talking about
before-- the green box.
We'll get back to that.
But anyway, when it
started, I thought, like,
oh, let's put together
some of my pizza boxes.
I had 20 or 30 at the time.
Let's put 15 or 20 pizza
boxes from around the world
on the wall and make
a little gallery show,
and then that will be the draw.
And the $1.00 slices
will be the afterthought.
I don't know why I thought that.
But people would
go, OK, now I've
spent some time
looking on the wall.
I had a couple of
really cool boxes.
A couple of ones that
weren't that cool,
but they were from
the Czech Republic,
and they were from
Turkey, and so
I thought that was interesting.
You know, see what pizza boxes
are like in other countries.
Because you already anticipate
that language and food
and money and customs are
different in other countries,
right?
But the pizza box is something
that, for some reason,
you don't expect any variation.
But then, of
course, there it is.
So I started collecting boxes.
I have this pretty cool network
of people who are really
into pizza from all over the
world who take tours with me
or do whatever, and I
can send out an email,
and I started getting
packages of pizza boxes.
And the problem is
that after this event--
well, not really a problem.
It's kind of a good thing.
After this event, they
kept sending them.
So I ended up with sort of a
growing collection of pizza
boxes, on a shelf, that's my
apartment in Clinton Hill.
I had to leave it because there
were too many pizza boxes.
But that top shelf--
every six months
I would flip it because
it would bow so much.
And everybody who ever was at
my apartment would look at it,
and then look downward at
where my computer lives.
And they would say,
like, bad idea.
Bad idea.
Oh, and even that
other shelf was bowing.
It was a terrible idea.
But anyway, people
kept sending me boxes.
And I had so many different
ways of collecting boxes.
People would come on tours
and bring me pizza boxes
from their home cities
or their home countries.
Sometimes with a full
pizza inside the box,
which was kind of weird.
But I remember this one.
These folks called me one day
and said something about, oh,
what time does the tour start?
We're coming in from St. Louis.
And as soon as I
said that, I said,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Can you bring me a
pizza box from Imo's?
It's this pretty significant
pizzeria in St. Louis.
In fact, there is sort
of a St. Louis style
pizza which has Provel
cheese, and it's
a thin, circular cracker crust,
and they cut into squares,
and it goes exactly back
to this one pizzeria
in the early 1970s.
So it was a box that
I felt like I needed
to have that box
in the collection,
and of course, they brought.
This one guy, not only did he
grab me this awesome pizza box,
but he stole a plate
from the pizzeria,
because he thought
it was really cool.
It had this embossed
little pizza guy on it,
and gave me this stolen plate
as well, which was kind of fun.
I just get all these pizza
boxes from people who will--
I'll get an email or a text
from some number I don't know.
My phone number is on
the tickets for my tours,
so I just get these random
texts-- meet me at this corner.
I've got a box.
I actually met someone
right over here
across the street by Chelsea
Market two or three years ago.
He was from New Zealand.
He brought me a couple boxes.
And I was just like--
I kind of wanted
to have a friend with
me, just in case.
It was just really weird.
I've got this one guy from--
I think he's in Sweden.
No, Norway.
It's Sweden.
He works for a pizza
chain, and he sends me
a bunch of their new boxes
every 8 to 10 months in exchange
for maximum strength eye drops,
because he can't get them
in his country.
It's the weirdest thing
ever, and I'm like,
I hope I'm not helping him
build some bomb or something.
I don't even know.
But it's just weird
things that happen.
I get packages sometimes.
People will email me.
Hey, I'm in-- like,
this one was from Japan.
Hey, I'm in Japan.
I want to send you something.
So I send my address.
No big deal.
But the package comes,
and it's like, even
the packaging is funny.
Because sometimes people
flatten down the box.
Sometimes they put cardboard
pieces on the outside
to protect it.
Sometimes they just
take a full pizza box
and wrap it and then send
it, which is really funny.
And they could get
crushed that way.
I don't know.
It's dangerous.
I should make a tutorial for
how to mail me a pizza box.
Maybe I should do that.
Maybe a video later today.
And it's funny, because
once you open up
a box like this
from Japan, boom--
there's a yellow box with
this weird teddy bear
character, which
I later found out
is a very popular
character in Japan.
It's like, the teddy bear
is just always chilling out.
It's always just laying down.
I don't really know why.
I don't know anymore behind it.
But the problem is, you've got
a box like this from Japan,
and then I'm always sort
of cringing a little bit
as I open it up, because
boom, it's been used.
Uh-oh.
Danger, right?
And not only has it
been used, but it's
been cut really bizarrely.
Whoever boxed this
up, clearly, you
know that it's a one
piece clamshell box.
They were standing
right at the opening.
They sliced it straight
down the center first.
But then after that,
they start in the center
and drag out for
all their slices
instead of doing cross
slicing, which, in New York,
you see most of the pizzas
are cross sliced, because it's
faster.
But this one, the person
went right from the center,
but missed the center
target every time.
I just love that
even seeing that, you
can tell something more by it.
And in Japan, I find that
their receipts are all
written into the lid of the box.
Multiple boxes that
I have have that.
It's really amazing.
But one of the questions
that comes up all the time
is do you also have a huge
collection of cockroaches?
And I say no, and
that's because I
have a method of
protecting these boxes.
So when I get a box,
the first thing I'll do
is take a razor
blade-- and I had
to have somebody take
pictures of me doing this
so I could explain to
people that I'm not
a disgusting human.
But you scrape out all
the cheese, of course.
This one was sliced a little
bit better, you can see.
But after all the
cheese is removed,
a thin coat of polyurethane
over the soiled spots.
That will seal them in.
No big deal.
It won't be sticky.
It'll be fine.
Dries overnight.
It's all good.
Only about 3% of the boxes
that I have have been used,
and so it's really
not that many.
And I don't have a whole
bunch of mice hanging
around the pizza box collection.
But one of the places that
I get some of my boxes
is at pizza trade
shows, which I go
to because I write for a trade
magazine called Pizza Today
Magazine.
It's a magazine for
the pizza industry.
Pizzerias get it in the mail.
I might have a copy of it here.
I think 40,000 pizzerias-- yes!
But it's embarrassing, because
the cover shot is a slider.
So I'm sorry about that.
Trust me.
Other months,
there's a huge pizza.
There's a centerfold of pizza
and everything like that.
But anyway, so I write a
column for this magazine,
and so that means that I get
to go to these events and judge
competitions.
And it's a lot of fun.
But secretly-- not
secretly, it's public--
but I, over the past few
years, have been going right
to the pizza box
companies, because they
have these huge displays.
They want you to see what
they can do on pizza boxes.
And in New York, nobody
spends money on pizza boxes.
They're all doing
really cheap things.
But here, you get
this huge spread,
and you find these insane--
like this company in California
has the largest pizza
box on the planet.
The largest deliverable pizza.
I guess this photo was
taken a few years ago,
but I got this box last year.
I had to go out to LA.
I was visiting my brother,
and we got the pizza.
We had 20 people try to eat it.
We didn't even get
through half of it.
And then I had to cut
the box a little bit
and mail it to myself.
And then, of course,
this year at the event,
I showed them the book,
and how in the book,
there's this shot right in the
beginning in the section where
I explain why I
collect pizza boxes,
and it's me standing in front
of that giant pizza box.
And they were like, oh, we
would have sent you one.
I'm like-- it was a $200 pizza.
But anyway, at events like
this, it's really fun.
Once the event is done
on the Thursday at 2:30,
everybody starts to leave.
And they're not going to
box up their pizza boxes.
They're not going
to take them home
and say, oh, these
are our samples.
We need them.
No.
They leave them as garbage.
And so that's when
I swoop in, and I
cherry pick which ones I
want, which ones I like,
and then it's so funny.
As everybody's breaking
down the event,
I'm sitting there
piling up boxes.
And then there's a
FedEx in the building
in Vegas at the Expo Center.
I just go there,
ship them to myself,
and then a week later,
it is like Christmas Day.
Because I don't remember
what I even boxed up.
So it's incredible.
But a lot of these
companies-- it's funny.
After a few years,
now they know.
They're like, oh, yeah,
you can take whatever.
Sure.
Oh, we've got a new one for you.
We'll hide it behind
these other ones.
It's so funny.
But I have some other ways.
Talking about getting into the
pizza industry side of things,
I started visiting pizza box
manufacturing facilities,
and that's why I put this
picture into the slide show--
because that is what a
pizza box manufacturing
facility looks like.
This is how exciting things get.
We're talking like
it's really exciting.
But it's really funny, because
when you get into these things,
oh, man.
As I was writing the book,
suddenly it was not just like,
oh, I'm a collector and I
want some of the pizza boxes.
It's suddenly like, oh, I'm
writing a book about it.
And it's funny, because I always
think about the convention
as-- do any of you
guys collect anything?
You must.
What do you collect?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT WIENER: Oh, really?
Whoa.
I hope it's not human
spines or something.
But, you know, some
people collect, let's say,
action figures, right?
Like sci-fi action
figures or something.
They have conventions for that.
And you can go and
buy them and trade,
and there's a whole
marketplace for it.
And eBay.
You can do whatever.
But pizza boxes, there is none.
I may be the only
collector of them.
And so therefore, when
I email a place and say,
I want to check out these--
I collect pizza boxes,
and I'm going to do this
book, they just let you in.
Maybe 10 years,
20 years from now,
there will be pizza
box collectors,
and it will be a
hard thing to get in.
So I'm just, like,
excited about these days
where I can walk into
a pizza box facility
and just walk around and be
like, oh, I want one of those,
I want one of those, and then
they just hand them over.
I got to hang out with
Manny at the place
called Rock 10, the
country's largest producer
of pizza boxes.
65% of the pizza boxes in this
country are made here by Manny.
But Manny was hanging out, and
he took me on this whole tour.
And the best thing
that happened was he
showed me their display
hallway, which was amazing,
because I was like,
wow, beautiful.
But then he showed
me the back room.
The storage room, where
they put all their samples,
which was unbelievable.
Because he was like, oh,
we have this one from 1996.
This one's from '89.
We haven't printed
it since then.
Oh, do you want any of these?
And I was just like, oh!
I drove up, I
emptied my whole car.
I drove back with just a back
seat full of pizza boxes.
And so I didn't even
have to lock my car,
because nobody was
going to touch my car,
you know what I mean?
It was just amazing.
He showed me all
these amazing boxes.
And then the problem was that I
had a houseful of pizza boxes.
And I don't keep them like this.
I took this picture the
day we were photographing
the boxes for the book.
But just to give you
an idea of the scope,
that is maybe about 100 boxes.
And at the time this picture was
taken, I had about 600 boxes.
So when they're compressed, they
don't take up much room at all.
It's just that
this was, you know,
to take some pictures of it.
But to be able to
store them, I had
to change my
mentality for storage.
Instead of having just
a little weak shelf that
was going to bow, I had to
shift it all a little bit.
So this is most
of the collection
as of maybe about a year ago.
And I'm pointing to the top
portion of a coat closet
where all the boxes live.
And I know it looks like
it's not going to work,
but you see three
stacks of-- sorry.
I was about to point at it,
but using the same hand that's
in that picture, and
it's really weird.
So I'm gonna go over
here and do this.
It's even weirder.
Greg, can you point?
No.
But anyway, these
are stacks, right?
And each one of those
stacks is one little bundle
of these boxes.
And this is two
bundles right here.
So there's a whole ton of boxes.
And I'm just looking
at it right now.
There are already bundles
in that little portion
of the closet right there.
But trust me, they
all flatten down,
and I kind of wedge some of
them up like a reverse Tetris
situation, and
they all fit right
in the top of that closet.
Except there are 50 of
them that are kind of
in the side of the closet on
the bottom, but most of them
are up top.
It's just that everybody always
asks, where do you store them,
after they ask
the bugs question.
So that's where they're stored.
Now I have 150 more
than I had at this time,
so now they are spilling
out into the living room.
But that's my thing.
I'll deal with that.
I'm looking for a
storage unit, maybe.
We'll see.
But the time came for when
we started putting together
this book, which is
published by a company called
Melville House
that's in Brooklyn.
And they just publish these
really weird and interesting
books.
And the president of the
company, in a meeting one day,
said, I read some article
that was interesting.
It was about pizza.
Maybe we should do
a book about pizza.
And then somebody in the
group-- this is a weird story.
Somebody in the group,
I had met years ago
when I showed up
to an open house
that I found on Craigslist for
an apartment in Park Slope,
and met this girl who
worked for this company.
I didn't get the apartment,
but years later, she's
like, dating a
friend's roommate,
and suddenly she makes this
connection at this meeting.
Oh, I know this guy who's into
pizza and does pizza stuff.
Maybe we should talk to him.
And then the president
of the company says,
yeah, you know what?
It would be cool to do something
about pizza box artwork,
because I used to have a couple
of boxes from-- they used
to be in Hoboken--
I used to have
some old boxes on the wall, and
that was really interesting.
Maybe he knows
something about that.
Then she calls me
up, and I'm like,
you don't even understand.
Because I was already
thinking about how
it would be great to do a
book, but I'm a little lazy,
so I never wrote
a proposal for it.
And then these guys call me
up, and they're like, come in
and we'll talk about it.
And I explained exactly what I
was into, what I wanted to do.
I said, you know, I
love the art of it.
But I also really want
to have some history.
And I told them I definitely
want a page or a spread that
was a glossary with diagrams
of different styles of boxes
from around the world.
And they were like,
yeah, we can fit that in.
And it was just an
amazing situation.
And so the folks from
the company-- they said,
OK, we've got to
photograph the boxes.
So they sent over
their art director
who just came to my
apartment, because I
said I didn't want the
boxes going anywhere,
because they are special.
And he came in.
We photographed a ton of boxes.
This is really amusing.
So Wa Ming is holding up the
lid of a reusable pizza box
to bounce light onto this
pizza box for the photo.
And it's just-- and we used
that photo for the book,
and I'm so happy about it.
It's like, I would love
to have a little comment
section in the book that's
like, we used one pizza
box to bounce light for this.
If you've gotten this
far into the book,
you will be amused by that.
You know what I mean?
But it was just really amazing.
But then we ended up with
all these photos of boxes,
and I had to figure out a
way to put them all together.
So instead of doing
something chronological
about pizza development,
which we sort of do,
but we kind of split the buck
up into different sections
about American classic
designs, portraiture, scenery,
that kind of thing.
So the classic
American would be one
or two color print
on a white box.
The OK chef, Uncle Luigi, I
call him, doing his thing.
That's total typical
American box.
This is a place in
Brooklyn, Sam's Restaurant,
which has two or three
typical elements.
It's got that
weird steamy pizza,
it's got the OK chef,
Uncle Luigi, over there.
But actually, wait a second.
It's just the reverse,
but beyond that, they're
pretty much the same.
It's just that I stare at this
exact image, and he changes.
There's two different ones.
There's one with no
sideburns, and then there's
one with sideburns.
But beyond that, everything's
pretty much the same.
So I just wanted to check that.
He's backwards.
It's OK.
AUDIENCE: That's got
the framing of the--
SCOTT WIENER: That's the
second element that I love,
which my buddy, Mark Bellow,
who runs a pizza making school
on the Lower East Side
called Pizza a Casa.
He asked me about this print,
because he was like, yeah,
I was thinking about
getting a tattoo,
like a barbed wire thing.
And I was like, you always,
if you have a tattoo or not,
everyone has an
idea of what they
would get if they were
going to get a tattoo.
That would be it for me.
Like, that would absolutely
without question be it,
and it's amazing.
Because it's this pattern
from the Northeastern US.
I tracked down the guy
who created that pattern.
And you only see it in
the Northeastern US.
So that's why you
can kind of track
where a box from by the
imagery that's on it.
And so unfortunately, it
didn't make it into the book,
but there is a page in
the book of the history
of this guy-- this chef.
But my dream is to track down
the guy himself, or his family,
and see pictures-- like,
family pictures of that guy.
And maybe he's doing that.
Maybe he's not.
I don't know.
But it's based on a guy.
That's somebody's uncle.
So I'm working on that.
We'll see if that happens.
But anyway, there's a
motif that I really love,
which is totally basic.
It's the proud chef motif.
He's standing in front of
an oven, a wood fired oven,
he's holding the pizza,
and it may or may not
say some words
that may or may not
useful to you as a
pizza consumer at all.
Pizza, oven fresh.
OK, whatever.
But that's the way
it looks in the US.
And it's this kind of
funny terrible line
drawing that's missing shading.
And I never thought about this
until a designer friend of mine
came to one of these
book events in Boston,
and he sat down with me and he
started coloring in the box.
And he's like, this is
what they meant to do.
But they didn't.
And then he colored it in, and
I was like, oh my goodness.
I never even thought
about it like that.
But that's our American version.
Totally simple.
Two color.
That's it.
But then the version
from Italy is full color,
and he's not holding the pizza.
He's so proud.
He's got his arms crossed.
He's so psyched.
He's got his tomatoes just down
there, hanging out, whatever.
Not a lot of cheese on that pie.
A weird double crust
situation going on.
But again, doesn't matter.
And then this wood
fired oven with a fire
that is not like
any fire you've ever
seen in an actual
wood fired oven.
But whatever.
That's the Italian
version of it.
But then you get to-- this
is from the Czech Republic.
And it's got a similar
thing going on,
but it's got a pudgier chef.
There's still the wood
fired oven, the arch
in the background,
the word pizza.
There's basil all around,
just like in the last one.
I love when you can
trace the same motif.
And they're not necessarily
copying each other,
it's just like, what would
you do on a pizza box?
Show the pride, and
the ingredients,
and have that be that.
And here's one from Israel,
which is standing right
in front of the
oven, holding a pizza
that if you look close
enough, each slice
has a different topping
combination on it,
which is ingenious.
And a friend of mine in
St. Petersburg, Florida,
invented this thing that you put
onto a pizza before you top it,
and it has separate little
separations, and this way,
you can top it.
And you bake it with that on
it, so it keeps the ingredients
from going on other slices.
It's crazy.
I don't think he's going
to use it for real,
but it was in his trunk,
and it was amazing.
But anyway, this guy had
it, I guess, in Israel.
But all the words
on the screen, it
says the same things
that our boxes say.
Like, hot and fresh,
and delicious pizza.
It's nothing new.
I love this other motif.
This is a more interesting
one, I think, of the
behind the scenes
chefs in the kitchen.
There's this is guy on the
left who's kind of by the oven.
There's the guy
in the front who's
cutting the finished pizza.
There's the brick all around
on the outside and the awning,
and then the bubbles on the
top and bottom with text.
So memorize that right now.
Bubbles with text,
awning, the word pizza.
OK?
Now check this one out.
Different company, different
artist, everything.
Awning.
Says the word pizza.
But now on the bottom,
there's different text.
And in fact, this text,
I think, is even better.
It says, enjoy your
delicious moments.
It's not just about pizza.
It's like a life thing.
It's like a fortune cookie.
Enjoy your delicious moments.
I just love that.
But also, if you look
at the artwork on this,
this is very clearly
multiple clip art sources
that don't match perspective.
The two people in the image are
clearly not of the same planet.
I mean, this guy by the oven
has this whole different face.
The guy in the front-- just
everything's different.
But if you go back
to this other one,
you can see, guy by the
oven, guy in the front.
It's just the same exact
idea, but it's like--
and one of these did come out
10 years after the other one.
And maybe somebody
copied it off the other,
but it doesn't really matter.
Nobody's like, I want to
protect the fact that I have
an image of somebody
making pizza on my box.
Nobody cares.
But it's just really
funny that even the awning
and all these things
are so the same.
Oh, and by the way,
I should point out
that this box
company has locations
all around the country.
And you can see this box in
the Southwest, the Northeast,
and in the Southeast.
This company-- if you
look really closely,
you can see there's a name on--
you can't see it in this image,
but on the olive oil,
there's a brand name.
On the can of tomatoes,
All these have brand names.
And this says quality right
on a badge on his shirt.
Those are all house brands
of Restaurant Depot/Jetro,
the supply warehouse for
restaurants, where restaurants
go and pick up produce
and pick up vegetables
and all that kind of
stuff, and dry goods.
This is a box that's printed
just for Restaurant Depot.
It does not say that
on the box, but you
could tell because of the
brands that are on there.
And this box in particular
is only available west
of the Rockies, because
of where it's printed.
And so you know when
you see this box,
you can tell the location.
So it's always funny to me.
I brought this up once about
how, you know, in a movie,
if you see this
pizza box, you can
tell where they're
shooting the movie.
And it can be a generic
box, but you can still tell.
And then a friend
of mine mentioned
donut boxes in California
are pink donut boxes,
and in New York, they're
white donut boxes.
And so you can tell
where a movie's
being shot by the color
of the donut boxes,
if your movie is about donuts.
But if this movie's about
pizza, then we know what's up.
But check this out.
This is packaging for, I
think, soccer uniforms,
and it's the exact-- here we go.
Camera one, camera two.
I love it so much.
It's the same image, and
apparently, this image
is enough to force
this person to want
to put it on-- you know.
And even if you look
at-- see the sausages?
Keep your eye on the
garlic and the sausages.
Those hanging things.
Boom.
Soccer balls.
Love it.
Of course that's where you
hang your soccer balls.
In your kitchen, where
you bake your shirts.
I don't even know.
But anyway, you've
probably seen this box.
This is the box that you
see the most in New York,
mostly on the streets,
like in the garbage
or meant to go to the garbage.
It's usually red.
She's holding up
one that's blue.
Which actually is
kind of interesting.
The red ones-- Italian
pizzerias get the red ones,
but Greek pizzerias asked them
to change the red to blue,
because they're Greek, and
they want blue on the box.
And so then they sell
these in different colors.
It's really funny.
In the collection, I have
one of every color variation.
So it looks like an Andy Warhol
Campbell's Soup can type thing,
but way better.
But in the book, part
of what I wanted to do
was I'm so interested
in these images.
Like, there are so
many images of a table,
a cafe with a full pizza,
two glasses of wine,
but two empty seats.
What's going on?
You know what I mean?
And this is like, I
have so many boxes that
have that same motif.
There's a bike laying over
here, there's no bike,
some of the bushes are
the same from box to box,
but they're different
companies altogether.
This one is amazing, and
I'm interested in this art
and how did it get that way?
So I went to the source.
This is the artist, Holly.
Holly Del Rey
designed this piece,
and so it's really funny.
Nobody had ever asked
her anything about this.
But I've seen this
box billions of times.
Like, when you think about an
artist-- you're an artist, OK?
And maybe you sell prints.
Maybe you sell a couple
of hundred prints.
There are 20,000 of these
boxes being printed every day,
you know?
That's a hugely impressive
number for a piece of art.
And so I just asked
her, how many meetings
did it take before this
image was the right one?
And what were the
problems with the image?
Oh, they wanted the
bushes a different size.
Oh, they wanted it to
be a more relaxed feel.
And then the question
always comes up.
I always ask, well, were there
ever people in the image?
And it's like, no.
There actually weren't.
The thing is, they want
to have an image that's
easy to duplicate, and
so the registration--
if it's two colors or more-- the
registration, if it's ever off,
it's not going to really
distract from the image itself.
However, I should have given
you guys a picture of this.
I have versions of this box
where the registration is
so off that the wine is
not in the glass at all.
And I don't count those as
boxes in my overall collection.
So, like, the Guinness
people would get mad
if they were like, well,
that's the same thing.
It's just printed wrong.
But in my private version
of the collection,
I love the screwups.
They're the best.
And there are some
pizzerias-- a lot
of the pizzerias in Brooklyn
buy misprinted pizza boxes
from the pizza box companies.
So you might go into, let's
say, La Villa in Park Slope,
and you might get a box
from Antonio's, you know?
But it's just printed wrong.
Or maybe they printed too
many, and Antonio's was
like, we're not buying.
I only said 5,000.
You gave me 10,000.
They might just buy
them straight out.
And they don't fold them inside
out to hide the other logo.
They don't care.
You already bought their pizza.
What do they care?
You're going to go
there again, because you
live in the neighborhood,
because that's
the way New York pizza works.
But it's just amazing
to me, things like that.
Now, this is Pat Trilli,
who is 94 years old
and he called me last week,
and I haven't called him back,
and I really should
call him back.
Maybe we'll all
call him together.
Who basically-- he did
not create the phrase,
"You've tried the rest,
now try the best,"
but he is of the
generation that did.
He started selling custom
printed pizza boxes in 1955
in Brooklyn.
Now he's retired
and lives in Jersey,
but he has this garage where
he has a bunch of old pizza
boxes-- just a
few-- and diagrams,
and letters from
Domino's explaining
to people about
how they're going
to go through a big expansion,
which was when Domino's became
a national name.
I have the letter-- well,
he has a letter of saying,
"Be ready to produce 3
billion pizza boxes,"
or whatever the number is.
Get ready to produce
a lot of pizza boxes,
because we need them.
And Pat Trilli was
the inspiration
for the image of this
pizza guy on the box.
And I'm sure you've
seen this box before.
This is kind of a big
box in the New York area.
But a friend of his
from the fourth grade
is the artist that did this.
And he originally
said, oh, I'm going
to make it look like you do.
And at that time,
he looked like that.
I don't think he was
running so much at the time.
But it's just amazing, the
people behind these boxes.
This is Ciancio.
This is the prolific
pizza box designer
who I asked him to send
me a couple of images
so that we can put something
in the book of him,
because I wanted people to
know who's behind these things.
And he sent me one where he's
holding the brush in the air,
and it's like one of
those Walt Disney things
where one of his
characters is there,
and he's just
holding a brush near.
We didn't use that,
but I loved it.
It was amazing.
I'll email it to
you if you want it.
But there's Ciancio.
I'm really interested in the
backgrounds of these folks.
That's one of his boxes.
He did that one with the
two kids-- the creepy kids
on the wall.
But there's another one.
There's pizza that's
always involved,
but it's always sort of
a passive participant
in the image.
See, he does things
with pizza boxes
that-- it's got a whole story.
It doesn't have
to have any words.
I feel like he's one of the
truly great storytellers
alive right now, because
he tells these amazing--
and you can make up
anything you want.
And I have another box that
has two characters, a guy
and a girl with a scooter,
and there's pizza involved.
But they're riding, right?
Well, this, I think
is part two from that.
This is-- there's been
some kind of an issue.
You're driving too fast.
You're driving me crazy.
Pull over.
And then he says, wait.
We almost forgot.
We got this pizza.
He's, like, trying to
get her back, you know?
And she's being
all, like-- you know
she's gonna eat that
pizza, but she's
being all, like, I don't know.
At least that's
what I think of when
I stare at this for
hours every day.
But I just love that
there are these stories.
And, by the way, you know that
this is going to work out.
Do you see that shooting star?
See it?
Everything's going to work out.
Ciancio knows it.
I know it.
But it's funny,
because Ciancio speaks
no English, so our interviewing
process was all through--
actually, through Google
Translate, so thank you guys.
And it was amazing, because he
would send these emails about,
like, I'm curious.
What is this book even doing?
And then when I sent him,
I just said, don't worry.
Just chill out.
I sent to him, and he was
like, ah, that's great.
Because there's a
little sketch of him
somewhere in here of just
like-- not the Walt Disney
version of it, but somewhere.
Anyway, there was some
little funny sketch of him
that I just thought
was really, really
funny to see this guy's image.
But I love branded boxes, like
marketing tie-in pizza boxes.
So these are some boxes
I want to show you
that are not in the book,
because of trademark issues.
But they're also the
only boxes I've ever
purchased online off of eBay,
and it's like six boxes.
It's all the ones I've
ever bought, ever.
And they're all these funny
collectible ones that came out.
This one was 2000, when
Episode I came out,
and it's pretty awesome, right?
It's pretty epic.
Only a two color
image, but of course
it's big companies
like Pizza Hut that
have the dollars to
do something like this
and to do big marketing tie-ins.
But then, of course, I just
couldn't-- yeah, right?
The Darth Maul one is badass.
It is.
But the Jar Jar Binks
one, that is goofy.
And it's like, you show
it to a bunch of people,
and you know when you hear
laughs, you're like, all right.
These are the right people.
But it's really funny to me.
And I have Anakin.
And somebody was selling a set
of four, and I'll never forget.
My mom called me, and she
was like, so what's up?
And I was like, well, you know,
there's these pizza boxes,
and I'm thinking
about bidding on them.
And I've never done
this with pizza boxes.
I don't know if
I'm crossing a line
with this collection
and all this.
Because the thing
about the collection,
and about collecting in
general, is a lot of it's
about the personal stories
and the interaction.
That's why.
I don't need to have
10 billion pizza boxes.
To be honest, one day, I will
be done collecting these,
and I will just set them on
fire, you know what I mean?
And I will just stand
there in a blaze.
Hopefully not in the apartment.
And I'll never forget.
She was like, how much?
And I said, it's like $50
or something like that.
And she's like, go for it.
And I was like, you're right!
It was just amazing.
She was like, go for it.
I was like, you're not
supposed to say that.
But one of the coolest
ones I ever got actually
came out April of 2013.
This was just a year ago.
Really, really fresh.
The R2-D2 Domino's Japan box.
How sweet is that?
It was $30 for the one box,
but it was worth it, right?
And it's a Domino's box.
Of course they're going
to do a tie-in like this.
But, you know.
He has the shape of
their box, sort of.
And the book is all
pictures of tops of boxes,
but I have to show you this.
The back of the box.
The functional explanation.
And, I mean, it's in Japanese.
I don't know how to read it.
If anybody can read
it, please tell me.
I mean, I want to
know how he works.
But it was just amazing to me.
The marketing in this box
is really-- the little
Domino's logo in the
lower right hand corner.
But it's such a cool
collectible box,
and I think it got
a lot of press.
I don't remember how
I heard about it,
but I guess, like,
I have alerts set up
for every time pizza
box things happen.
And it doesn't
happen very often.
But my other favorite thing are
the unlicensed, total ripoff--
this one's not in the book,
because I only got recently.
Anybody ever go to Paulie
Gee's in Green Point?
OK, so Paulie brought
me back this box.
He was on a skiing vacation
with his sons in the Alps,
and of course, he's
tweeting the whole time.
He's being such a nuisance.
But he sends me this image,
and he goes, you want it?
And I'm like, are
you even-- I was
like, if you saw that
and walked away from it,
I will never talk to you again.
Of course I want it!
This is the definition
of what I want!
They'd never license
images for pizza boxes.
I've spoken with Matt Groening's
lawyer and 20th Century Fox's
lawyer, everybody,
and they're like, no.
Because the reason
is-- I do have
a Simpsons box
that's in the book.
It's even better.
There she is.
It's almost like the
proud chef motif,
but they've taken Homer and
Bart and totally disguised them.
Oh, no.
Those are other characters.
This other one, it's
very clearly-- I mean,
come on, right?
Here, it's like, no, no, no.
Homer doesn't have hair.
Bart doesn't have a
bulge out of the back
of his neck or a spiky goatee.
And the physics of how
he's riding this skateboard
escape me, because it doesn't
look-- well, maybe he's
landing at Homer's feet.
I don't know.
I always think about it that
he's taking off, but no.
Actually, now that I
look at it, he's landing.
But anyway, the
image of this box
is the image on the
box within the box.
So it's even better.
And that's a whole motif that
people use all over the place.
Mostly in Italy.
And this box-- I got
it in Amsterdam, OK?
I'll tell you the name of
the pizzeria so you can go.
But it's a generic box.
He gave me the place.
I said, oh, can I
get a pizza box?
And it was kind of boring.
I said, oh, thanks.
I collect them.
And he goes, oh, I'll show
you this other one we have.
I don't know if
you're interested.
And he showed it
to me, and I swear.
I'm not exaggerating at all.
I blacked out.
I was with some friends,
and they describe the sound
that I made as like a screech,
but like a guttural screech,
as if it was like, [GROANS].
Like, that's what I wanted.
I'm always on the hunt.
I'd love to find some
unlicensed Disney boxes,
because that's, like,
Disney would probably
march in and set them all
on fire and walk away.
I want to get some.
I want that, and I want
some Ninja Turtles boxes,
but I don't think
they really exist.
I have one, but it's
recent, and it's bogus.
But something like
this is just amazing.
And then you get
interactive boxes.
I don't know if
you guys have ever
been involved with
interactive pizza boxes,
but it's kind of
catching on a little bit.
Domino's printed up
30 million of these
a few years ago as a partnership
with Hasbro, Parker Brothers.
I think they're the same now.
But where they wanted people
to have family game night.
And so you buy a pizza,
and then you get this game,
and it's Connect Four by Four,
which is a version of Connect
Four, but you can
have four players.
And each of the tokens, which
is the sides of the box,
they're all either yellow
or red on the outside
and then one of the colors
is different on the inside.
So when you put a token down, it
counts for both the outer color
and the inner color.
So your opponent could use that
piece to his or her advantage.
I've never played it,
but it seems interesting.
We actually we took a
photo of this for the book,
and it's really funny, because
after we took all the pictures
and I looked at the photo
on the book, I was like,
three different people
won in the version
that we photographed
for the book.
All we did was place
the pieces down
so it would look
like it made sense,
but that's a real fun fact.
But I love these
interactive boxes.
And this one's even better.
It's a company called PackToy.
This is an American box.
And it's an 80
piece jigsaw puzzle.
Because when you put
together a pizza box,
you're basically putting
together corrugated board
and stamping that with a die.
And that die is
going to give you
the score marks for the
sides, the cuts for the vents.
But why not make a
little puzzle out of it?
Well, except for the fact
that the puzzle may fall apart
onto your pizza, but
that's a whole other thing.
But that's what it is here.
But hold on a second.
So I was just in Brazil
like two weeks ago
where they had taken this
to a whole other level.
Same company, but in
Brazil, their boxes
are octagonal, first of all.
And second of all, each
one of these pieces
pops out of the box.
And if you can't
visualize it right now,
this picture from the
internet will help you.
Toy airplane.
Seriously.
And so I talked to this company
when I was working on the book,
and the company sent me
these promotional images,
and I'm freaking out.
I'm talking to myself, just,
like, I need to get this.
Where am I going to get it?
And then they're telling
you, oh, well, we
went out of business,
though, but we
sold a lot of those in Brazil.
And it's like, well, I'm
never going to get there.
This was a year ago.
I was like, whatever.
But I just knew that
oh, this existed,
and how this is like the dream.
And then last week, I
was at this convention,
and we were talking
about some boxes,
and one guy says, oh,
yeah, one of our clients
has a box that
becomes an airplane.
And I was like-- again,
I almost blacked out.
But the next day, he shows
up and he handed it to me.
He handed this to me.
And I just couldn't
even believe it.
It's like the Holy Grail.
It's amazing.
But that's not the only one.
They also have this one.
Dinosaur.
Right?
Dinosaur!
And I have this one,
too, but I'm never
going to take it apart, ever.
So I'm just glad that they
have these promo images.
But you take your pizzeria
and you have all your branding
on there, but then it
also has this thing,
and it becomes a toy.
Because the idea is, if
you have this pizza box,
it's really good marketing.
It's like a little billboard.
But the numbers are that
2.5 people on average
will see every pizza box.
So when you walk out of the
pizzeria, and you're seeing it,
somebody on the
street might see it,
some half person might see it.
I don't know how that works.
But what if you
encourage somebody
to keep the box around longer?
Then it's going to increase
the chances of your marketing
power.
So a box like this?
This one's from Japan, and
you can download an app,
and the app-- I would show it to
you, but it's only on my phone.
You won't be able to see it.
You focus on the box,
and it recognizes
the image on the box.
And it's sort of like
the way a QR code works,
but not totally boring.
Your screen turns
into something,
and you start to see this
character, Hatsune Miku,
starts to dance
around on the box.
And as you move the camera,
you're moving the angles,
and she keeps looking
at the camera,
and she'll dance at you.
And then you can go
closer and further away.
It's the weirdest thing ever.
Only in Japan.
And this was last year, too.
And it came out, and my
publisher emailed me,
and they were like, hey,
did you hear about this?
Too bad it just came out.
You probably won't
make it for the book.
And I was like,
give me two weeks.
I had it two weeks later.
I had to call this
guy I knew in Japan.
We were going to the pizza
Expo last year, and I said,
can you bring it?
And he brought it, and it
was the greatest thing ever
in my life until this happened.
Which is Hell Pizza
from New Zealand, which
I can demonstrate to you how
this works, because I brought
my dad's iPad, which I'm pretty
much borrowing from him just
for this.
It comes with this game.
Now, first of all, the
box is pretty neat,
because you can't really
see it, but there's
a perforation over here,
and everything for them
is hell themed and demon themed.
The perforation in the shape
of a coffin, which you pop out
of the box and you fold it up
and use it for your leftovers.
But on the side of the
box, on the coffin,
it says, "For your remains."
It's incredible.
So I want to try to
show this to you.
I'll see if it works.
This is really funny,
because the guys who
designed this-- they
sent me some boxes,
and then they opened
up the app outside
of New Zealand
for a short window
so that I could download it, and
it was the funniest thing ever.
So I'm loading this thing, and
I'm only hoping it'll work, OK?
But it says point at
pizza box to play, OK?
Now I'm going to point it at
this screen, and I'm hoping you
guys can see this.
I pointed it-- oh,
it's kind of weird.
It's kind of getting weird.
Uh-oh.
Point at pizza box to play.
Oh, my hand was in the way?
I hope this works.
Well, if not, I'll just
bring in a box next week,
and we'll play.
Oh my God!
OK, you ready?
Are you ready?
Can you see this?
OK, I'm touching the screen,
and it becomes a first person
shooter.
And in the middle
of the screen--
and it's much better
when the box is
flat on a table, not when
you're at bird's eye view.
But there's a pizzeria in the
center, and there are zombies.
Zombies who you have
to kill so that they
don't mess with the pizzeria.
And when you buy pizzas
from this company-- oh, man,
I've got to get real close.
I should come here all the time
and play on y our huge screen
here.
But you see the deal.
You move around, and
you can see on the sides
of it and the whole thing.
And it's their pizzeria.
And it's totally incredible.
There's my living room
floor, and there's
this weird scene
happening on it.
It's totally amazing.
But that would
definitely force me
to keep the box around longer
so I could play this game.
And then it's not torn up
and looking like a dinosaur.
It's sitting there as a
billboard for this company.
It's totally ingenious.
And I guarantee this is going
to be happening more and more,
because of course, there's a
bunch of investments in making
these games and
these interactions.
But once you can interact with
something like a pizza box
more, then it's not garbage.
Totally blows my mind.
So anyway, I wanted
to give you an idea.
I think now at this
point, you probably
understand why I collect
pizza boxes, all right?
It's like, there is
more to the pizza
box than just the
structure itself.
But there's also a lot to talk
about with regard to technology
of the box and its ability
to transport pizza,
and steam release, and
all stuff like that,
which I may have to talk
about at another time.
But right now, do we have time
for questions or something?
OK.
Now, if you guys have any
questions about anything pizza
related, pizza box
related, let me know.
I have a few minutes.
Yeah, what's up?
AUDIENCE: Do you
like to eat pizza?
SCOTT WIENER: I love it, yeah.
Yeah But no, it's a funny
question, because I mean,
I have to limit myself
to 15 slices a week
because of how much
I'm exposed to it.
So every day, I have
one or two tours.
Like, tonight, I have a tour.
We'll go to four places.
There will be leftover slices.
I will want to eat them,
but I have to keep a limit.
But I don't eat
pizza out of boxes.
Not out of respect for the
box, but out of respect
for the pizza, because the box
is the worst thing you can ever
do to a pizza, because
it traps so much steam,
and then the crust gets
soggy, and then that steam
breaks down the box
itself, and then
you end up tasting the
cardboard of the box.
So I love eating
pizza, but I don't ever
order pizza to be delivered,
even though I love pizza boxes.
But I love them as
an art form, not
for their functionality at all.
AUDIENCE: So you love pizza,
you love boxes, but [INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT WIENER: Yeah, what's up?
AUDIENCE: Well,
surely there must
be some kind of logical solution
to prevent all of those pizza
box problems from happening.
SCOTT WIENER: There are,
but they're expensive.
The problem is that the pizza
box is an invisible cost.
So when you buy a
pizza to dine in
and then you buy it
to take out, it's
the same price, even
though they have
to spend a little
bit more money.
In the US, you're talking
about $0.35, $0.45 per box.
It's not really that bad.
Brazil, they're
over $1.00, $1.50,
because they're doing
these crazy airplane boxes.
But there are a couple boxes.
This one is called
the impact box,
and you can get this box
at Eataly or Don Antonio
on 50th and 8th Avenue
or in southern Italy
where it has 17 vents.
Which is OK, but
what it really has is
the inside is a
metallic coating so
that it keeps heat
transfer on the inside,
and also prevents
grease from leaking
into the cardboard
of the box and making
it unrecyclable in
some municipalities.
But there's an
even better version
of the box, which is this one.
This is called the
Vent-It Box out of India.
And the way the corrugation
works is it's three layers, OK?
There's an outer liner-- I
anticipated the question.
There's an outer
liner, an inner liner,
and then a fluted medium, OK?
Now, what they do with
this vented box is instead
of gluing all three together
and then punching out the holes,
they glue the inner liner
and the fluted medium,
punch out holes, and then
they take the top paper
and they punch out holes.
And when they put them
together, they don't line up.
If you think about the
fluting like this table,
one hole on the bottom is here
and the other one on the top
is upstream, here.
So steam rises up, it
travels through the fluting,
and it escapes indirectly.
So since it keeps
a consistent level,
then it doesn't lose a lot of
heat, but it does lose steam.
So you do you have a
solution, but it's expensive.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So all do these custom
pizza boxes pay for themselves?
Or is it just an act of love
and they go this extra mile
because they really love boxes?
Or does it actually get them
more business subsequently?
SCOTT WIENER: Well, I mean,
it's definitely getting them
more business, without a doubt.
It's marketing.
If your box says
hot and fresh pizza,
then there's nothing to
indicate where it's from.
If the box says Jimmy's Pizza
Shop, then maybe you see it,
you see it on the
garbage pile, then
maybe the more often you
see that name, then you say,
I've seen that box.
Let's go to Jimmy's.
In my neighborhood, there's one
pizzeria that has custom boxes,
and they are busier
than the other ones.
And it's hard to tell if it's
that they make more money,
so maybe they're
spending it on boxes.
But I doubt that.
Nobody's going to be like,
hey, we have extra money.
Let's not keep it.
Let's make a cool box.
It's not going to happen.
It's marketing.
Big time.
And now pizzerias
is are starting
to get more into the marketing,
because they're realizing
you have to do something to
keep up with the next guy,
whether it's a
video game, or it's
coupons that pop out
of the box, or there's
something more
interactive about the box.
We were talking before
about the green box, which
is a box that has perforations
s it breaks down into plates,
and then a storage container
for y our leftovers.
And that's cool, because
it'll break down,
and you can leave it
in your refrigerator,
and it doesn't take up
a crazy amount of room.
So you're more likely
to keep that box around.
And it says right
on it, green box.
It's advertising for
the green box company.
But if your pizzeria
uses their box,
you can do your
own branding on it.
It will still say
green box on the side,
but you can do your own thing.
And then people
will say, oh, they
have that box
that's really cool.
We should order from them.
I don't think that
happens a lot right now,
but I'm hoping that will
happen more in the future
so that I will have more
awesome boxes to collect.
G-man.
AUDIENCE: Any
chance of us seeing
more of this in New York?
An artistic renaissance
in New York?
SCOTT WIENER: No.
I don't think it'll
happen anytime soon,
just because New York has such a
built in audience for pizzerias
that you're going to the
place on your corner,
or if you're going
out of your way,
you're going out of
your way for someplace
you read about online.
It's not because of the box.
New York is a different
world for this.
New York will always
be generic pizza boxes.
But when you go out into other
countries and other cities,
and so much more custom.
Colorado has a lot of custom.
Florida has a lot of custom.
But it's just really tough
to be in the New York market
and sell somebody on
custom and say, oh, here's
why you should spend
the extra $0.04 a box,
or whatever it might be.
I wish.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just curious, how do
your family and friends view
your collection?
SCOTT WIENER: I don't know.
It's funny.
When I started doing pizza
tours, that's weird, right?
But then they saw that
I was legit about it
and running it in a
serious way, and that there
was press about it.
And my parents could be proud
about it and talk at work.
My mom's colleagues at
work cut out pizza articles
all the time.
So I get an envelope every
month of all the pizza articles,
which, of course, we
have the internet,
and I already have them.
But it's so sweet.
It's so great.
So when the pizza
box thing happened,
I think they were already
kind of cooled off.
They knew that if I was up
to something, it was OK.
And then when the book project
came up, that's legitimate.
And now it's been on TV
for different things.
I just did an
interview yesterday
with the History Channel about
the history of packaging,
and pizza boxes in particular.
So when my dad sees
that, he'll understand.
He'll be great with that.
But it would be really funny.
I won't tell him.
He'll just be watching
the History Channel,
and it'll just happen.
And then he'll be like,
oh, man, it's real.
There you go.
Yeah.
So I honestly don't know
what their true feelings are,
but they haven't said
much negative to my face,
so that's good.
They're really
supportive about it.
I mean, they bring me
pizza boxes from vacations.
Good question.
Yeah, what's up?
AUDIENCE: What's the
conservation state
of the boxes?
Because you keep them
way past their intended.
SCOTT WIENER: Yes.
Do you mean, are
they breaking down?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SCOTT WIENER: OK, so since I
have these boxes from the '80s
and '90s that were
in a storage room,
and they still look OK, then I
think we're in all right shape.
But I keep them all
compressed, and I
keep them stacked
against each other,
so I think that's better
than if they were in a room.
I don't have them on display.
I have six or seven on
display, but they're
ones I have doubles of.
But I think they're OK.
I photograph all of them, so
at least I have the images.
And I just hope to not
touch them too much.
The more that I would tamper
with them, the worse it'll be.
Something did happen
recently where
we did an art show at my
publisher's bookstore in Dumbo,
and we covered the walls with
12 of my favorite pizza boxes.
And I had these
frames built that
were two pieces of
Plexi that pull together
to sandwich in the boxes.
And it didn't cover
it all around,
but it was a pretty cool
way to display them,
and it looked
really, really good.
And it's not confirmed
yet, but we're
really close to confirming.
We're going to do another
gallery show of 100 pizza boxes
in Berlin, and then in London,
sponsored by a company that
does food delivery in Europe.
Hopefully that'll be
confirmed next week.
But that'll be just
like this, and the idea
is you want to get people to
see that this is a funny thing.
You go out and check this out.
But it's also to have a
greater respect for something
that you thought was just
so simple and basic that it
needed no attention at all.
Like if one day somebody tells
me about different shoelaces,
at first I'll be like, no way.
But of course,
maybe shoelaces are
crazy and cool and
different, and who knows?
The flat ones and
the round ones.
I don't even know.
Now I'm thinking about it.
I'm getting nervous
that I'm going
to start collecting shoelaces.
Who brought up shoelaces?
It was me.
Anyway, good question, though,
about the conservation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT WIENER: I'm
not worried yet.
I mean, I'm looking
for a storage space.
And when I find one,
it'll have to be one
that I can have some
kind of control over.
Even if I can just put something
in there to absorb moisture.
But I'm worried about drying
out the boxes too much.
Right now, they're really
happy in my apartment
in a cool, dark place.
Wherever you store
your olive oil, that's
where you store
your pizza boxes.
AUDIENCE: Have you seen any
that have deteriorated yet?
SCOTT WIENER: Not yet.
The only reason
they deteriorate is
when I keep boxing them up
and then flattening them down.
I see little corners, you know,
like the flaps from the side.
I'll see them laying
around my apartment floor,
and I'm like, ah, another
one bites the dust.
Of course I want to
keep them all intact,
but I can't keep them perfect.
My fear with doing this show
and with doing the one in Europe
is that's a lot of
transport for these things.
They're not meant for that.
That's a lot of putting them
together and taking them apart,
and they don't all fold
up the same, you know?
So the differences between one,
like the Walker-style box that
folds up with a front flap--
you get into doing that,
and there's a rhythm.
But then you switch
to a tab lock box,
and suddenly you have--
they're going to be messed up.
So that's why it's really tough.
If we're going to do some
kind of thing like a big show,
then I would have to
photograph the heck out of it,
and I have to be ready to
kiss some of them good bye,
because they might
not make it, you know?
But what good is a collection
if you can't see it?
Good question, though.
Any other questions?
Well, thanks for coming out
and hanging out and listening.
We didn't even show
you a picture of food.
So that's weird.
That was one thing with
the book is I kind of said,
I don't want a single food
porn picture in the book.
It's got to be about the boxes.
And they were
totally cool with it.
So the only food in there
is photo quality images
of pizzas in Pakistan and in
Cuba, and they look disgusting.
So if you want to come
over and check it out,
I brought a bunch of cards about
the book and about the tours.
So if you're curious
about any of that stuff,
come and check it out.
If you have other questions,
I don't have a tour to
do today until 7:00,
so I'm just hanging out.
Although, no, I'm
going to the library
to do a bunch of
research, because I'm
going to start working on
another book pretty soon about
some more of the intense
history of some pizza stuff.
So there's all that.
If you have
questions about that,
come and let me
know, because that's
all I've been reading about for
the past few weeks in libraries
and looking at deeds
and stuff like that.
But thanks for
coming out, and have
an awesome rest of the day.
[APPLAUSE]